sie könnten ihre helme und gasmasken
auspacken sie könnten zu ihren waffen
greifen die auf keeper selbst ernannte
bewahrer des eids den alle amtsträger in
den usa auf die verfassung schwören
35.000 mitglieder hat die miliz
breiteste einer der anführer würden die
auf keepers es hinnehmen wenn donald
trump seines amtes enthoben würde wenn
die verfassung tatsächlich verletzt
wurde dann muss das verfahren
weitergehen aber wenn sie die verfassung
missbrauchen um jemand grundlos zu
attackieren dann ist das falsch
die auf keepers vor allem ehemalige
soldaten und polizisten geben sich
unparteiisch aber sie dulden auch
rechtsextremisten in ihren reihen
an diesem tag bieten sie den anhängern
von donald trump in dallas texas ihren
schutz an gegen mögliche übergriffe der
radikalen linken die fans huldigen ihrem
idol es ist nicht nur begeisterung er
treue gefolgschaft von 20.000 menschen
die der präsident unter druck wegen des
amtsenthebungsverfahrens zu einer art
waffe umfunktioniert gegen eine
vermeintliche linke verschwörung die
radikalen demokraten wollen unser
amerika zerstören in diesem kampf geht
es ums überleben der amerikanischen
demokratie macht euch keine illusionen
sie zerstören unser land aber wir werden
das niemals zulassen
mit seinen sprüchen geht es trump nicht
nur um wählerstimmen
denn in washington zieht sich die
schlinge zu immer mehr regierungsbeamte
bestätigen bei aussagen im kongress das
trump der ukraine die militärhilfen uhr
geben wollte wenn die ukrainische
regierung schmutz über seine politischen
gegner liefert deshalb setzt der
präsident auf die bedingungslose treue
seiner anhänger für das was da kommt sie
mögen ihn nicht nur sie identifizieren
sich mit ihr
er verkörpert was sie selbst sein wollen
mutig mit verachtung für die eliten
bereit die regeln zu brechen
um amerika zu dem zu machen was es mal
war so lange sie denken dass er auf
ihrer seite steht und für sie kämpft
werden sie hart für ihn kämpfen kämpfen
auch mit waffen das befürchten
politikwissenschaftler goldstone und
andere angesehene kollegen santa monica
kalifornien kritiker und fans von donald
trump geraten an ändern
ein mann mit einer make america great
again mütze sprüht ein spray das
eigentlich zur abwehr wütender bären
dienen soll
mehrere menschen werden verletzt was
wenn der täter eine pistole gezogen
hätte in einem land in dem beide
parteien extreme flügel haben und in dem
vor allem die anhänger des präsidenten
schwer bewaffnet sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hoffe dass es dazu nicht kommt aber
wenn trump beschließt dass er einfach im
amt bleibt trotz amtsenthebung oder
einer knappen wahlniederlage könnten wir
eine art bürgerkrieg in den straßen
erleben ein bürgerkrieg abraham lincoln
hatte einst als größte gefahr für die
einheit amerikas den aufstieg eines
anführers bezeichnet der sich ohne
gewissen und anstand selbst über alles
stellt diese warnung lincoln ist
erinnerte jetzt einer der trump aus
nächster nähe kennt und die unheilbare
spaltung amerikas befürchtet wir
ersetzen vertrauen und
einfühlungsvermögen mit misstrauen und
verachtung wir verbrennen unsere gegner
mit worten die kompromisse ausschließen
wir schieben die möglichkeit beiseite
dass andersdenkende manchmal recht haben
könnten wir betonen was uns trennt und
erkennen selten an das 1 1
in der reihe der amerikanischen
präsidenten gab es neben manchen von
historischer größe auch angeschlagene
charaktere bösartige narzissten
notorische lügner und trickreiche
kriminell
von alldem sehen kritiker ein stück in
donald trump der präsident und seinen
führungszirkel brandmarken das
amtsenthebungsverfahren als teil eines
kultur und glaubens kampfes an jeder
front führen die ultralinken krieg gegen
die werte die alle hier teile sie wollen
christen und andere gläubige zum
schweigen bringen und bestrafen
dies ist organisierte zerstörungen die
säkularisten und ihre verbündeten
kommandieren alle kräfte der
massenkommunikation der popkultur der
unterhaltungsindustrie und des
bildungssystems in ihrem unermüdlichen
angriff auf religiöse und traditionelle
werte
solche worte sichern donald trump die
rückendeckung seiner engsten verbündeten
der evangelikalen in den usa deren
anführer befeuern die spaltung amerika
sie predigen in diesen tagen eine
botschaft des hasses
die demokraten den präsidenten
erfolgreich des amtes entheben dann
befürchte ich eine bürgerkriegsähnliche
spaltung dieser nation die nie wieder
verheilen wird wenn die hölle losbricht
wenn diese leute in washington denken
sie könnten damit davonkommen dann
werden die trump anhänger sie zur
strecke bringt so wird es sein dieses
land wird in die dunkelheit stürzen
wir wollen wissen ob solche brandreden
tatsächlich gewalt entzünden könnten in
den warteschlangen in dallas stehen
amerikaner unterschiedlichster
wirtschaftlicher und sozialer herkunft
die meisten sind weiße begeistert von
trump steuersenkung von der extrem
konservativen besetzung von
richterposten und von seinem mauer plan
sind gewaltsame unruhen wirklich
vorstellbar unter den vielen amerikanern
wird es einen prozentsatz geben die das
verfahren auch wenn es legal war als
eine art fahrrad gegen den präsidenten
sehen also statistisch gesehen wäre
gewalt möglich aber es wird nicht weit
verbreitet seien
[Musik]
ich denke es läuft proteste geben aber
sie werden nicht zur gewalt greifen
das gibt einen aufstand vielleicht einen
neuen bürgerkrieg die amtsenthebung ist
unwahrscheinlich aber sie würde uns
republikaner nicht gefallen
sie müssen zu gott beten dass der senat
seine arbeit macht und das land
geschützt trump bewahrt die verfassung
sie darf nicht geschreddert werden sie
ist das größte dokument aller zeit
carolina ist 2000 kilometer gefahren um
geld zu machen mit der tramp euphoria
verkauft auch eine art prophezeiung für
20 dollar pro flagge trump wird alle
überrollen würden seine anhänger mit
waffen kämpfen wenn es sein muss wenn
wir für unsere rechte aufstehen müssen
dann sicher ganz bestimmt
drinnen in der halle zündelt der
präsident weiter nach den demokraten
sind jetzt die medien das ziel
[Applaus]
viele seiner anhänger halten trumps
worte für die reine wahrheit weil ein
präsident ja einen globalen überblick
habe so haben sie es uns gesagt
flankiert wird der hass auf unliebsame
medien von propaganda videos
dieses stammt zwar nicht von trans
wahlkampfteam wurde aber von ihm selbst
bis heute nicht verurteilt
wir treffen einen der einst den hass von
richard nixon gegen journalisten erlebt
hat tom broker bei während des
watergate-skandals nbc korrespondent im
weißen haus
nixon war geschickt darin die
öffentlichkeit zu mobilisieren die hatte
ihm ja schließlich wenige monate zuvor
noch den größten wahlsieg in der
geschichte unserer nation beschert er
konnte den gedanken nicht ertragen dass
man ihn rauswerfen wollte nixon wehrte
sich über viele monate gegen die
amtsenthebung doch die öffentlichen
anhörungen demontierten ihn stück für
stück die top blogger in seinem neuen
watergate buch beschreibt solch eine
erosion der glaubwürdigkeit werde auch
bei trump dafür sorgen dass die
bevölkerung seiner amtsenthebung oder
abwahl akzeptiert die fundamentalen
traditionen dieses landes stecken in der
verfassung und der rechtsstaatlichkeit
trump macht sich was vor dass die
menschen den aufstand wagen wenn ihm der
senat verurteilt einige leute werden
unglücklich sein aber wenn man es
methodisch und transparent macht wird
das land versteht
die anhörungen überzeugten die
öffentlichkeit weil nächsten die
geheimen tonbandmitschnitte aus dem
weißen haus herausgab auf gerichtliche
anordnung letztlich beugte sich nix in
der rechtsstaatlichkeit gehorchte dem
gericht und übergab die tonbänder das
besiegelte das ende seiner
präsidentschaft als die republikaner ihm
sagten dass er keine unterstützung mehr
hat trat er zurück um amerika zu helfen
das sehe ich nicht bei donald trump
bestreitet die rechtmäßigkeit des
amtsenthebungsverfahrens obwohl es schon
jetzt mehr als die hälfte der amerikaner
befürworten
der präsident selbst zweifel und findet
willfährige helfer in einigen medien
anders als nixon während weitergeht
damals haben die menschen auf die fakten
gehört ich hoffe dass sie das jetzt auch
tun aber ich sorge mich wegen fox news
manche leute bekommen ihre nachrichten
nur von fox und damit eben nicht die
wahrheit
und zur wahrheit gehört was manchmal in
der medialen erregung untergeht ein
präsident muss kein verbrechen begangen
haben damit eine amtsenthebung
gerechtfertigt ist dass im beach mit ist
eine politische beurteilung durch den
kongress dass ein präsident die
nationale sicherheit gefährdet oder die
demokratie zerstört oder er hat
erpressung oder andere taten begangen
die nicht genau definiert sind
dieser präsident hat eine unglaubliche
selbstüberschätzung erhält sich für
unantastbar aber in einem impairment
verfahren ist das exekutiv privileg sein
recht informationen zu verweigern
ungültig wir treffen eine die das fast
täglich erklären muss die
kongressabgeordnete medien die ihn
besucht eine notunterkunft für familien
in ihrem wahlkreis in pennsylvania sich
um die anliegen der menschen kümmern das
ist ein wichtiges signal in diesen tagen
auch beim bürgerabend wird klar dass die
teilnehmer vieles für bedeutungsvoller
halten als ein amtsenthebungsverfahren
gegen den präsidenten aber den ist als
mitglied im rechtsausschuss unmittelbar
daran beteiligt und warnt davor dass die
missachtung des kongresses durch donald
trump die demokratie und die
gewaltenteilung gefährdet dieser
präsident will offenbar die rolle als
der wahre und einzige spielen als
monarch er bewundert diktatoren und ihre
macht tatsächlich umgibt sich der
präsident mit treuen war sein die ihre
ämter dazu benutzen um die ermittlungen
des kongresses zu erschweren
ermittlungen die trump jetzt sogar als
lynchjustiz beschimpfte diesem
präsidenten ist es egal was die
verfassung tatsächlich erlaubt so ist
sein charakter er glaubt das was wir im
wahlkampf von ihm gehört haben ich
könnte jemanden auf der fifth avenue
erschießen ohne bestraft zu werden
das zeigt einen wahnsinn und eine
missachtung der verfassung die wir nicht
dulden können
trumps republikanische helfer im
kongress sehen das anders mehr
kampfbereitschaft hatte der präsident
von ihnen verlangt prompt machten einige
dutzend mobil gegen die bisher noch
nicht öffentlichen anhörung die
sozialistischen demokraten versuchen die
stimmen von 60 millionen amerikanern bei
der letzten wahl zu hintertreiben
zurückzuweisen für nichtig zu erklären
meine güte dann macht es öffentlich
verstecktes nicht vor dem amerikanischen
volk zeigt euer gesicht damit wir alle
die travestie sehen die ihr amerika
unterschieben volt und die entwürdigung
unserer republik
[Musik]
dann stürmten sie den anhörungs raum und
brachen damit regeln die sie 2015 als
republikanische mehrheit im kongress
selbst geschlossen hat solch rabiates
vorgehen gab es im capitol zuletzt in
den 1800 60er jahren kurz vor dem bürger
amerikas gründungsväter hatten als sie
das im pitch bend in der verfassung
verankerten vorausgesehen dass der
prozess zitat die ganze gemeinschaft
aufführen und in gruppen auch spalten
könnte würden einige heute sogar zu den
waffen greifen um eine amtsenthebung
oder abwahl donald trumps zu verhindern
das szenario dass mich umtreibt ist eine
knapp verlorene wahl der präsident
bestreitet die legitimität
verbarrikadiert sich und ruft seine
anhänger auf ein kontor ums weiße haus
zu ziehen um ihn zu beschützen dann
werden bewaffnete kommen
es gibt zehntausende die ihren
präsidenten mit waffen verteidigen
würden wenn sie glauben dass er
unrechtmäßig aus dem amt gedrängt wurde
würde donald trump sich wirklich weigern
das weiße haus zu verlassen
er ist unberechenbar und genau das gilt
auch für jene unter seinen anhängern die
ihn als heilsbringer verehren